vers qu'est la situation autour de vous
que se passe-t-il
écoutez je pense que la plupart des
habitants de calais ni cas même s'il
croyait à cette invasion russe ne
pensais pas que cette petite ville dans
le centre de l'ukraine seraient affectés
mais en fait si il y a eu des tirs
d'artillerie sur cette ville n'ont pas
d'hier mais avant il y est hier il y a
eu aussi un avion de chasse russe qui a
été abattu non loin d'ici on ne l'a pas
encore vu de nos propres yeux mais des
militaires ukrainien ici nous l'ont
confirmé ainsi que des médias locaux on
a été tout à l'heure au centre de
recrutement militaire de cette petite
ville qui est bien sûr un petit centre
de recrutement militaire mais il ya des
hommes dans la cour du centre il ya
vraiment beaucoup de monde ils veulent
rejoindre les forces armées et on l'a vu
sur la route aussi en venant ici à part
les très grand nombre de gens qui
fuyaient la capitale et d'autres grandes
villes pour aller vers l'ouest et les
embouteillages sur les routes on a aussi
vu cette résistance qui s'organise ait
des gens qui mettaient en place des
barricades des briques de béton des
choses comme ça on n'a pas très bien
compris exactement quelle était la
stratégie mais clairement il y avait
l'évidence d'une activité volontaire de
tentative de défendre l'ukraine qui se
met en place et il y à aussi à caligny
fifa il ya des gens qui sont venus de
kiev pour leur sécurité et les habitants
locaux essaye de s'organiser pour voir
s'ils ont besoin de quelque chose en
terme de nourriture couvertures des
choses comme ça on sent une grande
solidarité mais aussi une grande
nervosité pendant que je suis ici en
train de faire ce direct j'ai déjà été
contrôlé deux fois une fois par la
police et une fois par une citoyenne qui
voulaient vérifier m'a demandé d'où je
venais et m'a regardé d'un oeil à ces
soupçonneux jusqu'à ce que je commence à
lui parler en ukrainien et à lui dire
que j'habitais jusqu'à hier à kiev vous
reste